um well I've always been interested in
music you know I played instruments when
I was young and sang when I was young
and was in the band and the chorus and
school and I think somewhere in high
school I had decided that I actually
wanted to make a profession out of it
and become a professional musician and
then didn't do much about that for for
many years and you know like many people
went to college because you just just
what you do and then some point after
college found myself in New York City
you know not really knowing exactly what
what I was doing there and had a few
short-lived jobs and put a band together
kind of but never really did anything
with it played out a few times for our
friends and you know ultimately found
myself working in the software industry
writing code for a company in New York
and did that for about nine years and
kept doing music on the side recording
things and writing things just you know
for my own amusement mostly
it is true that I was in the
Whiffenpoofs in college and before that
the Sphinx those are two of the oldest
all-male a cappella collegiate singing
groups in the world so very proud to be
a part of them and the Whiffenpoofs
really were we're kind of one of the
reasons I wanted to go to Yale my dad
went to college there my grandfather
went to college there and so when I was
growing up they both had old records you
know LPS whiffenpoof LPS that they would
play for me so I was familiar with
collegiate a cappella music in a way
that many American kids were not I think
but uh yeah you know it I was thinking
recently some friends of mine from the
acapella community who I had been out of
touch with for a while recently came to
one of my shows in New York for the
first time and and as I was doing my
standard Jonathan Coulton show you know
I was thinking of them in the audience
and I realized how much my my schtick on
stage really does Oh to whatever it was
that I learned when I was doing acapella
because you know you you're in this
group of people and you know for me it
was a group of 14 guys all wearing
tuxedos and you're standing in a big
circle and you're singing you know
ironic covers of popular songs but also
sort of jazz standards and there's a mix
of stuff that you're really quite quite
serious about you're serious about the
music but you're also I mean you're
wearing a tuxedo and white gloves and a
white tie it's ridiculous you know and
you're doing a lot of funny stuff in
between the serious stuff and it's very
sticky and hammy and you know so i think
i actually took took a lot from that I
mean that's how I learned to to be a
person on stage I think and so at that
still applies to what I do in my show
even though I'm now you know a rock star
I don't wear a tuxedo anymore
code monkey is a song about a sad
software developer and you know I it's
loosely autobiographical it is true that
while I was working there I felt some
frustration about not not having allowed
myself to pursue what I believed was my
true calling you know and I was there
for I was there for nine years and and
it wasn't a terrible job I actually
liked it quite a bit i learned a lot i
had fun and good people there and so you
know I but there was that that vague
dissatisfaction so I used that when I
wrote the song but it is it is loosely
autobiographical the guy in the song
really hates really really hates his job
and in particular his boss I did not
hate my boss I loved I loved all of my
bosses and they were never they were
never as boring as I described them in
the song I'll save that for them